MARTIN OMANDER: Hi.
Welcome back to Root
Access, the show
on Google Developers Live
where we talk about startups.
My name is Martin Omander.
I work in developer
relations, and I'm joined here
by my co-worker, Don Dodge,
longtime investor and startup
advocate.
DON DODGE: Thanks for having me.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Don, we've had lots
of good viewer questions
come in as YouTube comments.
One was from [INAUDIBLE],
and he or she
asks, "How big does your
idea have to be for it
to be successful?"
Pretty deep question.
DON DODGE: It is.
Multiple layers to that answer.
So how big does the
idea have to be?
Not that big.
Here are some examples.
Carbonite is a company that
basically backs up your laptop.
And the first time I saw that
idea, I thought, that's silly.
You can do that
many different ways.
But it turns out
it wasn't silly.
It was a problem that
a lot of people had,
and they're now
a public company.
Dropbox is another example.
Dropbox is a very simple idea.
It's transfer big files
over the internet.
So it's not a complicated idea.
It's a simple idea.
But they are probably worth
several billion dollars now.
Twitter.
Twitter is going to
go public this week.
But Twitter is a
very simple idea.
It's basically instant
messaging broadcast
to whoever wants to subscribe.
So are those big ideas?
No, not really.
But they were
amazingly successful.
So I think the bigger
question is, is it
an idea that's scalable?
Can it scale to millions
and millions of users?
Or is it in a market where you
can generate tens of millions
of dollars of revenue?
So that's really the way
to look at that question.
Not is the idea big enough,
it's is it scalable enough?
I think a few weeks ago, we
talked about the difference
between lifestyle businesses
and venture-backed businesses.
And lifestyle businesses
can be very lucrative
and make you very wealthy, but
they aren't venture capital
kinds of high growth
exit kinds of businesses.
When venture capitalists invest,
they're looking for an exit
to get their money back.
Lifestyle businesses are more
cash flow profitable businesses
that may never sell.
So those aren't
the kinds of things
that venture capital investors
want to get involved in.
That's more like banks or
loans or that sort of thing.
Still very lucrative and can
make you very wealthy, but not
something that a VC
investor looks at.
MARTIN OMANDER: So these
lifestyle businesses
we're talking about.
What kind of-- like
retail, services?
DON DODGE: Right traditional.
Retail can be a very,
very lucrative business.
You can have one store and
generate $10 million in revenue
and be very, very profitable.
Or replicate that and
do four or five stores
and do $20, $30, $50 million in
revenue and be very profitable.
But those don't tend
to get acquired or exit
for 10s of millions of dollars.
So when you're thinking about
starting those businesses,
you look at different
sources of financing.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Got it.
Great.
Thank you.
We have another question
from [INAUDIBLE]
who said, "Very useful.
Thank you."
Thank you, [INAUDIBLE].
Just one question,
"What if a startup
takes place in a
third world country?
I'm going through this and
find it very difficult.
Any advice?"
DON DODGE: Yes.
There are several
examples of companies
that have started in third
world countries that simply took
ideas that have worked or
been successful in the US
and customized them a bit
for their local market.
So those aren't
that complicated.
It's just look at
something that has worked
in the US or another
market, and customize it
for your local market
and make it work.
And you can be
amazingly successful.
Don't be too proud to be
a copycat because there
are lots of opportunities there
where the bigger companies just
aren't watching.
Another approach
is solve problems
that are unique to your
market that may not
be problems in the US market.
So like SMS messaging
or money transfers
or like WhatsApp is just an
instant messaging system that
works across
international boundaries.
And so those are problems
that we don't have in the US,
but are very viable
businesses outside.
So either copy something
that works in the US
and make it work for
your local market,
or focus on a problem that
is unique to your market
and make that work.
MARTIN OMANDER: I assume
[INAUDIBLE] is also
in a less-developed
market having
problems with raising capital.
What are your thoughts
on that when there's less
developed venture
capital market?
DON DODGE: Yeah.
There's always a
way to raise money,
it's just the investor
expectations are different.
So in those countries,
they very well
may be investors who want to
invest in cash flow businesses
and lifestyle businesses.
So they might invest $100,000
or a million dollars and say pay
me back $0.10 on the dollar
of your revenue until
my investment is paid back,
and then I'll just have a small
percentage after that.
So there are different
ways to structure it,
but there's always a
way to raise money.
It's just a different
set of investors
and different expectations.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
I guess it could even
be an advantage to being
a third world country.
Your costs might be lower.
DON DODGE: Significantly lower.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Great.
Thank you, Don.
And remember, next
time blue shirts, OK?
DON DODGE: All right.
Very good.
MARTIN OMANDER:
[INAUDIBLE], [INAUDIBLE],
I hope those answers helped you.
Everybody else, please keep
the questions coming in,
in the YouTube comments.
So if you're a cloud
developer and you
want to run on Google's
infrastructure,
then you can get a credit
and you can get started.
The details are on the screen.
It's a $2000 credit
to get you started.
Go ahead and sign up.
I use the Google Cloud
platform all the time
for writing my Google
internal app for my team.
That's it.
See you next time.